We're going to start
with a moment--
a few remarks from
Provost Garber.
And I just want to
pause for a second
and mention that,
when HILT first began,
we did some research on what
makes an initiative like this
to improve teaching and
learning culture at a university
successful and what
makes it unsuccessful.
And one of the key
attributes in the literature
is regular systematic
endorsement
and championing from the most
senior of our leadership.
And so I just want to say
how lucky and wonderful
it has been to have
President Faust,
Provost Garber be at
every one of these events.
And it's because of their
care in the teaching
and learning mission.
And I think it has made a
huge difference symbolically
and substantively
their interest.
So help me welcome Provost
Garber for a few remarks.
And then I'll come
back, and we'll
set up the exercise that
we're going to do over lunch.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, Erin.
I just want to thank you
Erin and the health team
for once again organizing
a terrific conference
on an issue that matters
hugely to Drew, to me,
to basically everybody who cares
about teaching and learning
at the university, which I
hope means everybody, period.
These meetings have
been really instructive.
They provided a way for people
to get to know each other,
to set up collaborations,
to exchange notes,
basically, about how
they deal with challenges
of teaching and learning.
And I want to thank all of
you for taking the time out
of your busy days to be here.
Let me just say briefly
about the topic today,
about evaluating teaching,
is one that's obviously
of extraordinary importance.
And I don't know if Tom
Kane is here right now.
But Tom Kane of the
Graduate School of Education
had very kindly sent me
some of his notes about what
are the most important
findings from the literature
on evaluating teachers in
the K through 12 setting.
So there's really a lot there.
There's a quite
a big literature.
And I couldn't possibly do
justice to that literature
or even to his summary
of that literature.
But one of the things
that really stands out
as an important finding
is how there is great--
much greater within
school variation
in learning outcomes
than across schools.
And there is much greater
within school variation
in teacher quality.
And furthermore, the teacher
quality, as it's measured,
is fairly persistent.
That is, there tend to be
good teachers and not so good
teachers.
So if you're a student,
your learning outcomes
depend, in some respects,
almost as much on which teacher
you get as in which school
you are assigned to.
And this means that the teacher
is also, from some measures,
more important
than, for example,
the specific curriculum.
So clearly, evaluating
teaching, at least in the K
through 12 context, is
extraordinarily important
if you care about
learning outcomes.
Now, I've taught in a variety of
settings in my teaching career.
And they include, of
course, large lectures.
It includes working in a
business school setting, where
it's highly interactive.
See The grades
for the students--
I taught at Stanford, but
the rules are the same here--
50% of the grade is based
on classroom participation.
It's an incredibly
easy, engaging setting
to work in when you have
those kinds of incentives
for the students.
I've taught small seminars.
And I've taught in
clinical settings.
And clinical settings,
I mean really
in medical clinical
settings, where it's
a small number of students.
It's highly Socratic.
You know whether they understood
either what they've read,
what they've seen in a patient,
or what you've told them--
you know almost instantly.
There's no hiding it.
And in each of those
settings, the teaching task
is somewhat different.
And the evaluation tests--
the quality of teaching,
is typically measured
in different ways.
In clinical settings,
although it's
possible to be
evaluated by someone
other than a student
or a trainee,
it's a little more difficult
than in lecture settings.
One of the other things
I learned in my career
is basically how there's huge
variation in how different
parts of the university
evaluate teaching.
And here, I don't
really want to bring up
any embarrassing facts.
But suffice it to say
that in this regard,
I think business schools--
and I use the plural
here, because I
think this is common--
sort of set the
standard, in that
faculty sit in on
lectures or the teaching
sessions of other faculty.
That's part of the
promotion review process.
And they get feedback.
And even in very
large courses, it's
quite possible that
faculty members will never
have their teaching evaluated
by another faculty member.
Of course, we do have student
evaluations of faculty
all the time.
But it's really
not quite the same
as knowing that your
promotion, for example,
depends on the views
of your colleagues
on the faculty in
the department.
One of the other findings
that Tom mentioned from the K
through 12 literature is
that, not only do people not
like to be evaluated--
not a particularly
surprising result, I know--
but in fact, they don't
actually-- a typical faculty
member or a lecturer of
any kind isn't typically
aware of what they're
doing wrong or right.
And they have memories of
their sessions teaching
that don't necessarily
comport with what
the students have observed.
And in fact,
according to Tom, this
is why video is so
important in helping
teachers of any kind to
understand how they're doing.
Because with video, depending
on what the video focuses on,
you can start to see
how the students have
kind of blank stares
at a certain point.
You can actually see how the
faculty member did not directly
answer the question
that the student asked.
A lot of this, it's not
that people are exactly
self-deluding, but
we aren't wired
to sort of process
this information
and be objective about it.
But we can't deny it when
it's put in front of us
in the form of a video
of the teaching session.
So it's tremendously important.
And here, let me just mention
something that many of you
know about.
And it has to do with
HarvardX and edX.
And of course, both HarvardX
and HILT, as well as
research operations
sit in the Vice Provost
for Advances in Learning's
office, Peter Bol's office.
We started edX in--
we actually formally
announced the creation
of edX and HarvardX in 2012.
But it had its roots
really in 2011.
And I arrived here as
provost in the fall of 2011.
And there was a
committee that existed
at the time I arrived called
something like Harvard at 400.
So we were just about to
have the 375th anniversary
of the founding
of the university.
And this committee was thinking
about what Harvard should
look like in 25 more years.
And for some reason,
they had gravitated
more and more toward the
importance of online learning
and to the opportunities
it represented.
As part of this
process, the committee
invited a couple of professors
from MIT to meet with them.
MIT at the time--
still has-- they had the
OpenCourseWare initiative,
which was a very
broad initiative.
I know many of you are
very, very familiar with it.
But it includes online learning,
all kinds of course materials.
But there were videos
of MIT faculty teaching.
And these MIT
professors said, you
know what's really interesting
about this experience
of OpenCourseWare?
For the first time, when we
put our classes out there
on the web, the whole world, of
course, could see our lectures,
but our colleagues
could see us lecture.
[LAUGHTER]
And they talked about what
a profound effect that had
on how they approached
their teaching.
They cared in a different way.
So, of course, the
light bulb went on.
And I heard this.
Members of the Harvard at
400 committee heard this.
And I realized that this
new set of technologies
that we called online learning,
and later it was about MOOCs--
the terminology really
doesn't matter, could not only
change how we make what we have
to teach available to students
broadly, it would
actually change
how we approach teaching
in our classrooms.
So think about the video.
This is like the typical video
taken to the n-th degree,
because when you do a
formal online course--
and this really was taken
to a whole other level when
we created HarvardX, where we
have production teams helping
with these courses, all kinds
of scrutiny at multiple levels--
you have a kind of evaluation
that you would rarely, if ever,
see in a typical
classroom setting.
And in fact, this
is one of the things
we're trying to measure--
how our efforts
with online learning
are affecting
teaching on campus.
Not every faculty member
who does an online course
has the same reaction.
But we've heard from
several of them.
People who had very
high ratings as teachers
in their regular
courses, they talk
about how the experience has
transformed their approach
to teaching.
So I've spent a little more
time talking about that
than I really intended to.
But the bottom line for
me is that we really
need to think about the
forms of evaluation that
are feasible that
people who lecture
and who teach in other settings,
other than lecture halls,
will find acceptable, that
they will participate in,
and how they can incorporate
them into their teaching.
Of course, we care
about content.
Of course, we care about
learning styles, and so on.
But fundamentally, if
we don't figure out
how to improve our teaching, we
will now make all the progress
that we might in enabling
our students to learn.
So thank you, again,
for participating
in today's events.
This is-- obviously,
your work is
central to the mission
of the university.
And I very much look forward
to hearing the outcomes
of today's conference.
Thank you and enjoy.
[APPLAUSE]